[Musique]
ce qu'il faut dire de Falaise
pouvoir enfin du fond de son lit
ainsi qu'un gorge sur une chaise
une paire de bas sur un tapis
nous les coureurs impénitents nous les
dents Gigi nous les noms
chaque fois que l'on renifle
la piste fraîche du jupon
pour un baiser brune gifle sans hésiter
nous repartons
le seul problème qu'on se pose
cette séparé en deux portions
55 kg de chair rose de 50 g de nylon
c'est pas toujours un jeu d'enfant pour
eux dont je joue pour un Don Juan
mannequin la manucure
[Musique]
nous les noms
mais il arrive que le cœur s'accroche
aux épines d'une jolie fleur
ou qu'elle nous mette dans sa poche sous
son mouchoir trempé de pleurs
[Musique]
c'est le danger le plus fréquent pour un
don juif pour un Don Juan
[Musique]
nous les gros croqueurs de souris
pour nous
on apprend un petit
[Musique]
nous sommes les lumières
et quand la mort viendra sonner
nous dirons notre prière
un
chapitre
[Musique]
en attendant
le jugement
nous l'aidons juju nous les dons
[Musique]